Hallo Bushido!
Meine Frage an dich:
Bist du wirklich kriminell?
Hast du schon mal was geklaut?
Muss man selber so was erleben,
um wilde Texte zu schreiben?
Meine Frage an sie wäre gewesen:
Findest du dich wirklich witzig?
Na ja was heisst kriminell?
Ich hab schon mal geklaut.
Ich hab auch schon Sachen gemacht,
die verboten sind.
Ich war beim Verkehrspsychologen,
als chronischer Rotampelfahrer.
Das reicht auch um einen in
Deutschland für kriminell zu halten!
Ansonsten betreib ich keinen
Menschenhandel
und bin auch nicht
in der Prostitution tätig.
Ich erpresse kein Schutzgeld,
weder von deutschen Bäckereien
noch von türkischen Dönerläden.
Ansonsten würde man eher sagen:
Na ist er doch nicht kriminell?
Im Endeffekt versuche ich natürlich
nicht als Krimineller zu protzen,
weil man bei Sachen erwischt wird.
Ich würde einfach mal sagen:
Der Geniesser schweigt!
Und solange man nicht erwischt wird,
ist man auch nicht kriminell.